whoop-whoop so baron you're wearing that
dude right he I'm wearing the best damn
Analytics band in the world it measures
your sleep message your recovery
measures strain and measures basically
it measures your heart rate and
everything else how many calories you
burn pretty much everything to the nth
degree right yeah it's the best man I'll
cycle my dad today which was gone an
hour hike we got lost it two hours and
my dad goes oh we've walked over 10,000
steps that's probably about three and a
half miles and now he had his he Herson
of the whoop no it wasn't no didn't have
anybody you got a different editor a
different we had is it something else on
yeah and he goes oh it's about three
something miles I said how many calories
think we burned dad his I don't know
price six hundred and I brought up uber
I've been I just because you can track
it right when you're gonna do a workout
you can decide swimming weightlifting
running biking psych whatever you gonna
do I put Uther's hiking I put hiking I
did it right when we started and I had
exactly how far we went how many
calories we burned our heart rate our
average heart rate our max heart rate it
may be a T but I was like Jesus I'm like
telling you man we need to get you one
of these cuz I'm Tom about woop there's
no one better in the game to measure
your heart rate also you can also as a
with your professional athlete just a
regular person when you're working out
you also know what day's the best days
for you to really train hard what days
to rest it Mars your sleep it does all
of it yeah it's got a battery life too
so you know I thought but the battery
just slip on you just slip it right on
your charges slip it off you don't
enough take this off really know that's
how good it is mam usually lasts about
five days mine laughs a little less a
little longer it's heart rate monitoring
and then some join the club
right now you guys get $30 off your
first purchase by going to whoop calm
that's wh-whoa Pete calm use the code
fighter at checkout and save $30 and
optimize the way you train that's
fighter for $30 off at whoop dot-com
what time do you have to be don't worry
about it let's rock and roll you know
what it is dude we have our podcast and
that's the most important thing and and
I want it I want to say
this you're you're probably still on
your Kido your look is skinnier now
you're gonna lose the bed that's okay
well that's okay you're not gonna be 235
that's hilarious but here's the thing
here's the thing you're looking a little
vulnerable because my guess is you need
some carbs not even admit you sure
though yeah you look soft in the eyes
you look you have kind soft eyes oh
you're good
you might burst into tears at any second
that's how I know I'm good man I have a
dad any my babies no zero you feel good
feel alright well do you feel cuz I'm
older now and this is what happens to me
maybe it's never been different some
days I wake up and I feel like I'm in
cement like I feel like my body's kind
of caked in cement 88 and I got a I got
a really get the old what buer here you
came a little bit late cuz you were
stuck in traffic
I've been on the floor here doing that
stretching and talking yeah but I mean
really upset have you been on your feet
only 14 hours that's 14 hours yeah
that's what does if I'm standing and
standing kills me oh dude a knee or
walking standing standing sitting in
there on it if I'm chillin I'm good but
that's standing a long time yeah kills
makeup it is what it is it's not real
work I don't like saying I work for a
living but it's it's always weird when
people say this yeah it's a lot of time
there it's not work if it's your passion
now I get it it's a lot of work though
well we did one scene yesterday we're
all sitting around a table we did one
scene I was just told because it was a
hundred and ten times let me say it
again well say it again we did the same
scene hundred and ten times in my head
if on the director I'm like we need a
different group if it takes the 110
times to get this right yeah we need
someone else yeah the scene was written
in a certain way where you have to get
every angle it's very difficult to not
do it that many times well yeah I was
told that now I don't know if that
wasn't true so I'm gonna have to go back
and see if that's true if it is we're
gonna have to throw a little bit of a
thick here's a problem I love my
director he's a pro I love my I love
everybody on the set so they're doing it
they're all great so they're if they do
it that many times there's a reason so
if I complain there
I'm gonna embarrass myself because
they're gonna go you're gonna give you a
reason why they're gonna go here's the
thing dude here's what's going on it's
the writing and I'm gonna go home set
the best with this I got like this I
don't need I've never I'm not directed
there was shooting they're shooting the
reaction shot this way they're shooting
the reaction shots and I was off-camera
and I was saying the line for the 50th
time and I go do we have to go all the
way the end and I just I hear my
director who I respect a lot go yeah we
do yeah there's a reason they don't know
oh okay they don't know [ __ ] it's a team
in it it's too [ __ ] there's no you're
on your Antonio Brown I'm Antonio Brown
there's no more of a collaborative
effort the only it's of such a team
sport
it's crazy yes and everybody who's
behind the scenes I've never seen any
that no one's late and problems get
solved immediately I've never seen
anything like it if you've been in the
business that positive is to I mean if
you're gonna be late or of course it's a
well-oiled machine yeah no this time if
you ever want to read other mind behind
everything talking about if you want to
write a book on Hollywood if you want to
write a book on Hollywood and really get
dirt you get you get the no no no no
well know what boring book is I'm out
talk to the grips no you talk to the
[ __ ] hair and makeup people yeah
never say anything there's a therapist
that you want you don't open their
mouths you know I don't give a [ __ ] how
close you are they will never spill the
beans ever they might say something like
this I worked with him what's he like
he's some different complicated to
different yeah it's all right I remember
I wanted to ask I want to get inside the
mind of the the makeup ladies in haired
people at ESPN when I was when I was
there when I was working yeah they were
painfully hot now seeing of all the guys
that come through I mean all the bigwigs
that come through there and they do
their makeup you talk about Ray Lewis
Michael Irvin Kobe Bryant the who's who
is always running through there and I'm
like God because these are alpha male oh
yeah I'm like there's no way a few of
these guys haven't just pull out their
old floppy [ __ ] I've been there I've
been well I dare say
story about how one of our one of our
makeup people floppy [ __ ] flopped
because I ever tell you the story I'm in
on MADtv we had a hair person who was
transgender and she was basically full
up well in fact she went through the
full up while we were doctors a season
yeah in our seconds so was Jim showed up
as Jane yes and she was always always
felt like a woman inside she took her
sister's birth control pills when she
was 14 she was just a girl
I never thought of her as a man yeah
that's cool and Roy Jones jr.
the great Roy Jones jr. at the height of
his career the man yep he did a scene I
think it was the first year of MADtv he
did a scene and we did the makeup and he
got right up in her face and he goes man
man if you was a fighter man you look
right through people you look right to
people man you just sexist and he was
right up in her face
I mean press and hard because he thought
she was a woman he thought it was a
woman better was and I am ER saying to
her I said you know I said just be
careful because you know if he finds out
that things are a little bit different
it could be you know he's no joke and
and because I knew who he was I was
nobody else ago because I was like
that's Roy Jones jr.
and she goes well he's the one coming on
to me I mean he just like so hard and I
was like I know that because you never
know are sexy she looked really good I
have a friend who has a friend and she's
uh she almost save it is but it's a
famous trans yeah like really famous and
she said she went through her DMS yeah
you should see who's the nerd en oh I
believe it I believe it cuz I you should
see her like you should see is it a day
and I went but I like yeah I go so there
Gayle you know there's not that they're
gay it's just like a lot of these
transgender have their specially the
ones that go from men to women they're
so feminine like they get so feminine so
in the night
dick well the guys like it I I could
tell you a story about being on my set
of MADtv and my the woman who does hair
her friend who was full up and had huge
tits whose did it and a [ __ ] and hips
and was gorgeous lot of yeah everything
and this was 1996 before technology will
be a little dicey
I don't give a lot thanks ladies I
happen to know maybe I do and maybe I
don't got an actor who may have been or
may have not have been a guest star or
was on the show at one point or another
apparently they were getting changed and
he might have pulled his dick out and
gotten it sucked and a O'Brien oh all
Brides a straight man right yeah you
were in the guts no but I I was like I
was eyeing him up her up iron her up and
I'll be honest with you your opportunity
presented itself to me I would have done
it you know and I would have done it
with that I'm glad you admitted this I
just thought of it but here's my thing
dammit it's when it's it's confession
Thursday if confession Thursday only
don't do it on Wednesday that's right
and you Kat and Cheney gets in chimed in
on this if let's say you had a friend
yeah who was a guy yeah and then that
guy just had the does all the hormones
as the transition into a female and
she's a bull [ __ ] ten blonde ass if
you think and then you started dating
her yeah that does that make you a gay
man I don't think so not really right
I mean because some of them are so
feminine well okay so explain to me how
I'm gay if the person used to be a man
but now has huge tits a crazy ass and a
full mouth and a makeup no no no that's
not some of them all and you have it but
dude I was you can't interrupt me I know
it's like you can't interrupt me with
sucking and [ __ ] because what happens is
I go right you just rode me off no I
didn't say that strange cuz I don't want
to push anything out of the way that'd
be a distraction on both of these that
thing in my face can't have a big old
group air tell you my friend who saw my
route
and he goes you got a good route on you
man as we left the car because the
things that happens sure I was hanging
with this girl he was hanging her maybe
were and we were in view of each other
and he goes dead serious goes good time
man good to hang with you bro hey you
got a good you got a respectable route
how's my god oh man he'll where's he
later bro don't say it all serious and
shake my hand like it's an accomplished
range yeah don't don't don't
it's not an accomplishment that's so
good rude on you man dude I was doing a
late night midnight set at The Improv
last night and Jeff Ross and Craig
Robinson were up there just [ __ ]
right yeah and Jeff Ross is going
through this weapon remind me of
transgender he's doing the roast of
Caitlyn Jenner yeah
and he's going through his jokes right
now and I think he's shooting it soon
and they are so freaking it's fire it's
so good but they're the opsi super
offensive because the transgender sure
it's so far and then Jamie Kennedy if
supposed to close the show but Craig and
Jessica he's ready to go he's doing the
roast on Comedy Central so he's you know
high and tight ready to go so they're
doing it killing the crowd and then he's
a great who's next and Jamie Kennedy's
in the back you know Jamie sure Stephen
King's back he goes no just keep going
man I can't follow this just just end
the show and he goes well you know I'll
come up there with you and I in my hand
I thought god I would not go up on that
stage with Jeff Ross right now yeah in
roast mode yeah he's King Jeff's like
he's trying to leave he's like hey get
up early Jamie's like I'll go up there
Jim King goes up there and Jeff lit him
on fire
I was gonna leave other gone man it's so
weird dude I was like I'm just getting
off
I stayed oh my god really on cuz he
called me up on stage call me about God
and interviewed me as Chris Walken but I
thought he was gonna completely roast me
and I was like all right Jeff apologizes
and listen man that roast mode right now
so I'm attacking everybody's noting it
but my guy I mean off yeah James Cain
can be an easy target it dude it was
[ __ ] yeah Jeff that's his thing yeah
he's the roastmaster he's the [ __ ]
roast master I did then one of the best
rooms last night
um I after 14-hour day I'm grabbing a
bite to eat
I get a text you close oh my
oh I said yes to a gig and it was at the
Venice underground have you done the
Venice underground house got to get you
up it's it's it might be in some way
it's best room in the cut in instruments
are for me it is it might be the place
for our homie for do one Wednesday
nights it might be the best room like in
in a lion a lot really farting for me
him bring up the Venice on the ground
take a look at the city's altar with you
one time visit in the backyard no man
it's underground it's in the oldest bar
and is it uh where the Windward circles
yeah hmm that's great I what there's
something I forget who I went there with
I need you to do it I wanna do it no
it's far for you I know but it went a
night when you know one Wednesday night
we'll do it we'll do a set at The Comedy
Store and then we'll drive down I'd be
done for that cuz we can do it at like
10:30 yeah packed it's always packed
yeah and it's hard to walk around that
mean you walk through there one time I
remember that a long time ago really low
ceilings yeah dollar yeah dark is like
you don't have a burlesque show after
yeah that's right get a little dicey I
did it I did last night and then the
burlesque show was talking about with my
old neighbor and that's that's there
upstairs which is an amazing bar real
great speakeasy
it's called town house mm-hmm and we did
I know it's funny because I was I did my
set I'm talking my boy and then I
there's a burlesque show yeah and the
ladies come out yeah and there's she
they're dancing she's dancing to in
stockings and she's dancing on the floor
to baby I'm the only one
hey is she sexy oh I just got a little
embarrassed hi this is gonna be sound me
I'm gonna buck man I was like you're
dancing around in fishnets but it was it
wasn't and be like whoa but it was just
well you're not stripping well that what
you're also he was kind of stripping
here's why it's a bummer yeah when she
moved LA she thought using me Julia Rob
yes dude [ __ ] she's dancing to that ah
yeah and the floor is all filthy I'm not
to be a dick but it wasn't a stage I
feel some time all been everybody's been
sitting there watching comedy with their
feet now they moved the chairs and she's
sliding around and I was like dude she's
really is the least of her consult and
and I'm like everybody's constant and
I'm like that looks like a really strong
cry for attention and it's not the
artistry is a little lacking it just
bummed me out and I looked at I gotta
get out of here and being me did you
throw her any cash I didn't throw her
any cash I just ran away I felt it's
exactly what I felt I felt bad for him
you feel you feel bad and I and she's
probably great and I just felt [ __ ]
shitty I had a group of throw ice at me
last night onstage at the improv what
group of Mexicans threw ice at me wait
you heard my Mexican bit I think I'm mad
at you oh yeah they did yeah and they
threw I see you yeah
they threw ice yep what happened
ah the security isn't kick him out like
no I'm still in stay them stay and I
just kind of clown them for a little bit
yeah cool like win him over
I want him over yeah but yeah yeah they
just need to know that you're not being
they know that I mean everyone's having
a great time they know but it's like two
drunk ones so all they hear is the last
bit of it I know like this Trump tag
that I have so they hear that it's like
out he's a trump guy and then throw this
ice did you rob she had a set of tits on
her and what you the only reason you not
getting kicked ass cos you have huge
tits
yeah well that's the only reason I said
no that letter says just enjoy shitty
and she threw ice she threw ice yeah big
titties though yeah so I said you could
stay I think that's the right move
oh me too I don't never throw never
never never kick you out Double Down but
it also gives me something to men talk
to
yeah it was late just lay this one I
think here what are we gonna do include
him yeah yeah yeah
streams though right I had a woman I did
this Africa bit about how white
celebrities adopt black babies because
you know it's like yeah yeah and it's
like a [ __ ] that it's like an
accessory right you know like the more
the famous area the more black babies
yeah and I do this whole thing about but
if they can never adopt they can never
adopt an American black baby just drive
right over to South Central and get your
monster care but no I have to fly I'll
do it to Africa you know first class
yeah it's this bit and it crushes it
learns crushes please and there's just
one woman like this hmm
my dad and I go what's wrong white girl
of course well super it's always the
super woke the super woke are the white
the white privilege ones I go to well
it's my I dug wells in Uganda and I had
a false alarm
oh did you dig wells am i are you
protecting the continent Africa huh
white girl are you standing up for the
Africans I'm making fun of people like
you you virtru signaling [ __ ] yo-yo
it's just humble you she's totally
mister Joe just miserable and I just
stopped and I try to debate it
everybody's clapping for me I'm like you
know you're you you don't like black
people more than I do and you're not
more sympathetic to the cause just
because you dug wells [ __ ] began not
walk out of here
they just don't the problem with the
with super woke anybody on either
extreme I don't care if you're right
super level anything you're super you
just lose your sense of humor cuz you're
you're into orthodoxy mmm not
open-minded at all this judge oh they're
already made up their mind yeah true
there's no winning yeah they have the
truth you know I mean it is what it is
you're as I told you you're the Antonio
Brown of your caste dude yes you see
what's going on with him today I bet you
every Pittsburgh Steeler fans like there
you go the [ __ ] did we tell you there he
was the problem so I don't remember yet
so he's the best receiver he leaves the
best of receiving the league so he goes
right picks for it's like given the [ __ ]
at her because he was a cancer right
he's talking [ __ ] about all the team so
he goes the the Raiders they trade trade
for him everyone's like oh this is gonna
be great for derrick karr he's gonna be
such a good player so that he gets there
and then he's not practicing because he
doesn't have the right helmet he's
wanted to helmet but he don't have to
right helmet so I think everyone seems
like sticking up what he wants if we
watch Hard Knocks he's on Hard Knocks
and John grooms like you know I'm not
mad at him I wish he was at practice but
he's sticking up for something that he
that he respects and that he stands for
first half most Americans don't at least
he's sticking up for something and
that's why I'm me okay cool but it's a
little weird helmet what are we doing
you paid so much money then yesterday
they firm in those practices it's just
mr. standard practice is you get fined
that's the rules if you don't practice
she a fine so they find a $54,000 which
isn't much to him he makes a shitload of
money so he shows up practice next day
tries to fight the GM of the team for
finding him tries to fight the gia tries
to fight me so what's this say allegedly
burned to hit him in the face yep I
wonder if summer this is a CT III think
some of this is DT Deva yeah I think
he's a bit of a diva okay yeah dude how
much is he getting how much is he making
um I'm not sure but anytime you try to
fight the GM who basically brought you
on board and here's things he's not with
the team you know like a lot of guys
respect them for year extension worth
sixty eight million nineteen million
guaranteed there you go make him Braun
the highest-paid receiver in the NFL
he's the Betty's the I wouldn't one of
my my team but he's the best is he such
a diva it's cancer has he always been
that way yeah always
mmm-hmm well I shouldn't say always but
at once he started to get to that level
of elite then he can then he can act
like that and people put up why did he
love it yes but the minute you stop
producing it's like actors who the
minute their movie started doing poorly
see you later
what what what um why did he leave
Pittsburgh they want him out of it hey
Jay answer yeah he's not playing the
league but he was talking [ __ ] on
everyone and doing stuff they traded him
wow he just sit him down
hey it's just a bummer because it you
you want you watch them on
hard knocks in the season finale on
Tuesday watch over hard loxias kids and
you're like he seems like a cool dude
yes like it probably is but he's also a
diva
what's Keyshawn Johnson that's who I was
thinking about the other day we're all
over the most the receivers that get
that level a lot of them have these
insane egos man yeah in its its heart so
there's this kid right there's three
kids are so adorable but they have
they're sitting there practice and then
one little boy in you know Antonio Brown
and Ben Roethlisberger hate each other
right turmoil hate each other the one
says this why he left one says this way
they were losing so they hate each other
Ben Roethlisberger's more valuable yeah
for sure but so they there at the
practice shows the little kids and his
little son you know he's like threes
like Tigers age go back come back to
that hold on so it sounds like threes
like Tigers eight she goes papa
where's Roethlisberger at and you can
see in sauce camera he has no idea he's
miked up and turnarounds Bubba he's not
he's not here this is a different team
he was worse bad that where's uncle
banner Oh something like that it's funny
man I have a problem don't but don't dye
your mustache blonde like that don't do
that can't do we can't do that don't do
that you know you know he's from I think
it's Gables that County in Miami yeah
we're all like there's a shitload NFL
players that come out of there yes he's
one of those guys okay yeah because
University of Miami is no not used for
my ego you know from that area is from
an area I think it's Klaudia Bulls
ballgame yeah that's right Cordy I see
it sees from a similar area where where
it's like all this these super ballers
come out yeah yeah it's just a freaky
it's such a bummer man with Antonia
Brown sake just what makes him so good
what what does Hank however it's one I
want to coverage every time or what too
fast too good of a wrap runner amazing
hand that smart smart as far as smart
foot bike you real smart yeah but he's
so fat like one on one and they they
talk a little bit of hard knocks
he's literally impossible to cover you
have to bracket him did no one's there's
not a corner in the leak just cuz he can
he can break he can he can just rest
rat running so so good yikes I still
root for a man it's just such a bummer
yeah well let's go ahead when they show
the kids let's let see the kids again
that mustache out of there and also
let's get a better attitude and have
that now okay usually that's a pretty
cool hairstyle cool fashion but that
that mustache is a nightmare you know I
didn't lay em why what's like when he's
going through all this turmoil with the
Pittsburgh Steelers then he's on that
that [ __ ] show on thought I think
it's the worst show that to ever be
created where there were that's like
monster sing and you're like who is it
oh yeah the Masters yeah his name is
show hit though that's the that's the
problem
yeah well yeah and OJ Simpson has a
million followers on Twitter it's the
problem with the world okay and the math
seniors in the number one you know I
came from Korea just shuffle translated
I guess it doesn't translate its it I
watch I'm like what the [ __ ] is
happening right now
and they're all let me guess am i'm
favored the judges they guess they go
let me guess man you say you grew up
singing zip out Lee Jong I'm like you
stupid the flies so he's Elton John its
famous people like who are the masks in
behind the mask yeah so Antonio Brown
was one of them oh but it's but he was
singing he was doing something uh Nick
Cannon yeah never said no to a gig in
his life and was that Ryan around yeah
he was I guess he was in the Korean one
dry roads isn't on the American one but
it's but the the bastard the guess is
like you said you grew up dancing
hip-hop okay
is it Kanye West like honey it's not
doing your shell bro no honey it's not
doing your sin so weird it's always like
that you know it's always like be level
yeah you know I'm saying sorry there you
go
but they never get it right either like
it's not there's not like a is it Tori
Spelling I did a [ __ ] thing for Fox
where me and another
had to pretend we were totally in the
Tori Spelling we were doing these skits
and we're like well there she is
yeah and I was never very attracted to
her of course
and and I was too young to have said who
wrote this oh go [ __ ] yourself
definitely not like I was like I'll do
anything you tell me to do you know who
it's tough well Wow she lied she looks
like my grandma she had a tough time
because she was never will her dad right
you know it's just that she was around
so many beautiful people as a young girl
and she wasn't classically beautiful
like her mother and like those ugly
duckling it was a serial the nine oh two
one oh and so she got the showed what
happens to pretty young girl like that
is she's an actress she gets put in
because her dad is a television icon she
she gets plastic surgery it's terrible
to be that you know you feel like it's
very hard to miss she don't look like
Wendy Williams if there's white chicks
to share on battery photographs of her
for sure no I'm just saying like what
growing up in this [ __ ] town Brody is
economy and you're a regular looking gal
yeah she starved herself you could see I
remember I remember
nice girl nice [ __ ] girl but grew up
in the biggest house in Southern
California it's bigger than a white
house I've been in it and she cuz of her
papa
oh yeah well her dad her dad for one
Christmas don't hedging well I had her
dad had snow brought in had a snow no
jeans Oh Torah
Aaron Spelling in spell he created yeah
every TV show he was eight until is
multi billion probably everybody Aaron
Spelling was the biggest man on TV he
was a TV legend and and she grew up with
this legend and she said I have to be a
knowledge new and and a movie star and
you know that's not wasn't her destiny
it wasn't though she took her MoMA know
her mama mama-mama her mama was the
hottest thing on her car her mama was
the hottest thing she wasn't bad when
she was younger though but she wasn't
the only thing but she wasn't gorgeous
like the girls on 902 or now but you
have to see her mom her mom
was so hot Candy Spelling when she was
younger the biggest hits the bigger the
growth she was a Barbie she said it she
goes I was Barbie and I wasn't Rachel
she's bringing up the Barbie that's
melted in the Sun oh no and she was
younger forget it what I worked with her
she was delicious but especially when
she was younger
I'm sorry she had kicked off Coraline
she was not so much be their way though
you know I was younger what is well what
is what is Hollywood is tough
Hollywood is they're all ugly when you
put your when you when you decide you
want to be there where she was now she's
breathing but your crazy curves and but
when you decide that you know when
you're in this town where beauty's
commodity and you're not and you decide
to get into that business you can have
some trouble the fun you though it's on
you that's like you being upset if you
get criticized as a UFC fighter or if
you get mad you got a black eye you know
or if you're a football player you get
your bell rung it's literally what
you're signing up for yes if you're in
the entertainment it's pretty cutthroat
man I just had a conversation it I'm
going through negotiations with Showtime
yesterday
right now for it to you know my
contracts and in December so there's
been ongoing negotiations and they
called me yesterday go okay we got this
and you know do you want us to sugarcoat
it you want us to tell you exactly what
we went over on it oh definitely don't
sugarcoat it trust me let's go to the
bottom [ __ ] line you can just hit me
with exactly what they're bringing to
the page yeah and they tell you like
it's nothing I don't it's nothing I
haven't you're a capitalist is what am i
worth here's the word that now here's
what I think I'm worth let's look at a
horse nurse that they say this I say
this and meet somewhere in the middle
that's all
it's called negotiate you what though
man the one time boy and I think this
wife thick skin down like haters or
social media or anything doesn't really
get to me is because I'm officer when
you're fighting you could tked all the
time but I remember Lex McMahon who I
still deal with shelter let's link that
kills it for me he's great great guy so
he was negotiating my contract when I
was up in the UFC and went riding the
car and he goes ah ha cha Silva's called
it's about
Contracting you guys I'll just call them
back I don't want you here to see you
do you don't give a [ __ ] just don't
because you won't say a word I will say
we're just just answer the car and just
answer the call in the car I'm a big boy
I can't handle eggs I wish I never did
the house oh dude I mean your honor
you're a horse
ah you're a [ __ ] straight huh anyway
horse training insecurity you ever had
about being a fighter anything like if
you're like well now wasn't that better
this was an oh dude yeah you're just
talking about the most vile venom you've
ever heard about yourself
ah and he got off and he goes in
Mexico's and that was a mild rant from
him that was a mild rant because I've
had he goes if I if I use all my clients
if I'd let them listen to the
negotiation they would all quit I said
I'm not gonna call it but Jesus man my
buddy as I tried to tell you my buddy
was a very big director he said he said
I stopped taking not getting auditions
personally when I had a long talk with
him he said well dude let me tell you
how it goes let me tell you what it is
it's all horse training right all right
if you want him we don't like him but
we'll give you him if you give us this
cuz we need and it's just like you have
season I like that
it's not worth it's not trading horse
trading no it's right which it's what is
it then it's just like no they're like
what yeah he's like what the [ __ ] you
comin he lost this guy that this he did
theirs he these are the rain they have
he'd they're right this though like it's
not like uh I can see that it's kind of
dry it's very yeah I'll take this and
shut up yeah Oh gonna go and then
finally he goes you know what let's go
somewhere else then we don't need
anybody go somewhere else then okay all
right well - okay well what was it
it's just silver did good job but now
anything you do great you're brilliant
man here I used to have like animosity
towards him and in the UFC brass Joseph
was a brilliant man he's very
brilliantly he did he was great at
picking and great and that's what he had
because Rogan told me they'd be up on
like fighters that's the that's the
nature of the game like that's why he's
there yeah
he was a brilliant man yeah but you got
to realize how sad a fighter
since if you are like when I when I
fought Lavar Johnson or or I should even
go back even before that when I fought
cro cop before that cro cop Pat Barry
and beat him right but they were so
friendly that it wasn't the fight that
it should have been I remember when I
got the fight they flew me out to do
some announcement and Joseph what comes
up me goes you better not play [ __ ]
pattycake with him you better in you
know Joe Silva's five six yeah he's in
my face going you better not play patty
[ __ ] slap with him you better kick
his ass I was like yeah man of course
geez so that happens what rate great
fight for me knock him out then I get
Lavar Johnson right few fights after
that I get Lavar Johnson and I asked for
the fight cuz I saw some weaknesses in
his game and it was a we were the main
event on Fox so we were the big fight
right before it was a pay-per-view which
is super important well I'm not gonna
[ __ ] trade blows the Lavar Johnson
they take him down to him down
1 million times flawless victory for me
I didn't get touched but whatever so
there I am legally look at the third one
in this one yeah like I knew us can take
some [ __ ] for it so I just took him down
over and over and over Luc Renard was
his corner man by the way oh really was
talking [ __ ] to me in the back you guys
I love Luke yeah yeah music you know you
don't want to fight like what the [ __ ]
you talking about pretty boy I don't
really know Luke at the time so but Joe
Silva is in the back any season I go
when the window you know most takedowns
in a long time in the heavyweight
division and you just look saying it's
not [ __ ] believable he keeps going up
ah god damn and then lex goes and then I
always ask Lex cuz I would have left be
my filter I go where we at man let's go
can't fight like that again like but
I've dominated him they can't like they
goddamn if you were to hear and they
that's really fighting about a John Finn
said if I were to lost that one that
would have cut me [ __ ] you better went
to the judges and for a reason the
judges gave me like a shitty decision
which you'd have to be blind I destroyed
him but they were cut me
again here's the like when you're in it
and you know think of it you're so
sensitive and it's like but that's the
nature of the gorse
of course in the NFL Buffalo blue I mean
you're right you think oh you think the
UFC is brutal cuz that you're dealing
with less guys more one-on-one very
black-and-white
well then FL it's not ass
black-and-white right because there's
some guys who are really good who get
cut if you watch Hard Knocks you you
watch some of these guys like how the
[ __ ] did I can I'm like the theme
there's just a numbers game and this guy
knows this guy and maybe he played with
this guy's dad whatever this guy made it
over him yeah Danah fell I mean they're
just like yeah man he's just you're not
good you just thought there's not fit
you're too slow right yes the ball y'all
oh yeah no [ __ ] I did you try to back
tough not a big deal
now I've only been working on this since
I was seven I did always wonder why you
were pretty fearless I always call you
fearless you know because you would
stand up you would just go up and no
matter what and what the competition was
but after going course I've always been
like yeah you have I guess you have
you've always been here talent shows
what I'm just not you're just not afraid
if you're maybe even if you are you just
do it it's yes yeah
my god most people are just afraid I
mean including me well I'm people are
afraid you know but one of the things I
noticed is that I'll see people behaving
in a way where I'm like I've you know as
I get older I got to be honest I mean I
see people whose lives depend on
behaving a different way than their
lives because they have an illness or
whatever and they just don't and I go
you mean what do you mean changing their
diet when they're sick oh I know I mean
you're gonna die crazy you're gonna die
alone I'm there there is science to
suggest you should eat this way because
it'll really help you and it might not
do it and they don't do it in fact they
continue to do this and you go or even
somebody I helped out who had a child
and I I tried to help them with
scientists I know and they just didn't
pull the trigger and I go you realize
that I go this is much bigger than help
you you know what to do this is some
weird psychology you have to get you got
to get out of your own [ __ ] way
that's like most people are in their own
I know what it's like my grandma didn't
know growing up but you know obviously
you know because my grandpa had a lung
cancer from smoking so much and the
doctor tells them hey he has yes stage
whatever for lung cancer there can be no
smoking in the house no smoke in the
house so my grandpa has that octagon my
grandma's neck stone of course smoking
like a chimney I'm like did you not I'm
four he heard the [ __ ] they've already
decided not figured that because they
have it's it's it's it's it's a I I
really think I've said it before I said
again success is really about learning
how to talk to yourself and how to get
out of your own way how do you get out
of your own way everything else is I
hear these people call me up I get this
whole time I know you did too but III
indulge in it I get these questions
people go hey can I pick your brain on
this now well but you know the answer
you know the answer you're asking me a
bunch of fake questions because this is
more procrastination oh and by the way
they want you to help them you're not
gonna listen to me but you're not gonna
listen my experienced might my case
study being 52 is almost no one almost
no one does it no one does it what do
you mean oh what the advice you give
them yeah I mean I don't know I always
tell you I'll annoy you wish yeah and
there's no one [ __ ] takes the advice
and nobody you're not really asking for
advice you just want to feel safer he
does my foot look seven foot long it
does it looks like it's a long ass but
of all time it looks like you can ski on
those I think it's a huge dog you know
bro is there something interfering with
your happiness or preventing you from
achieving your goals you ever think
about that well look sometimes you need
to talk to somebody somebody who can you
can talk to you that you can trust that
is a licensed professional who's been
there before and can recognize patterns
and see what you're about and that's
where better help comes in yeah
sometimes just talking to friends loud
enough no you can start communicating to
a professional in under 24 hours it's
not a crisis line either it's not a
self-help thing it's actually
professional counseling done securely
online and there's a broad range of
expertise and better helps counselor
network which may or may not be locally
available in many areas okay worldwide
the service available world you can log
in your time and send a message to your
counselor at any time yep it's more
affordable than the traditional offline
counseling and financial aid is even
available for those that need it visit
better help calm slash fighter and join
the over 500,000 people taking charge of
their mental health with the help of
experienced professionals and you can
schedule weekly video or phone sessions
you need man they're for you chapter ear
off fighting the kid listeners you guys
get ten percent off your first month at
better help.com slash fighter get your
mind right you want to live hard you
want to live clean you want to live
optimized we know there's one company
that does not compromise you know I'm
saying you would happen right now happen
we must be on out the brain you know
she's talking about on it bro on
everything yes dude on it calm slash
fight or a little alpha brain little new
mood maybe you want some melatonin
rather want to sleep better yeah man how
about some creatine so we can get Jack
city
how about shroom tech immune or how
about just shroom tech and general if
you want to work out extra how about a
little krill oil to get that skin right
literally everything you want including
exercise about fitness gear they got it
check you want some Star Wars on it
kettlebells want valorous ropes bags
balls clubs maces how about you need a
training program we got that on at six
kettlebell on at six steel mace they got
it all streaming easy apparel shirts
shorts backpacks socks performance gear
audit comm slash fighter 10% off get
yourself
oh you'll see that new yet tonight
brother oh I want to see that it's three
hours long though my lies director
producer David Katzenberg produced that
approves the first one - what did you
say chin there knew it I thought the new
year was out like a a while ago yeah bro
chapter 2 for I don't know there's a
shower - and let's watch the trailer I
ran out a lot - huh
no there
I saw in its everywhere he's supposed to
be scary good yeah it looks really
really really good same people hours
long though no mo you don't know
anything about it chin they're grown-ups
now dude you never saw the first one I
didn't see the original movie which I
thought was amazing
so so you do know the pain goofy when
you look at so the fur is to Deva is to
VHS is even the first time wasn't the
first one with skids second one with
their adults this one I like Jessica
Chastain so much I have an inappropriate
such a good actor oh I think she's oh
you know what I finished last night was
minehunters on Netflix oh yeah
which other killer it's so good I was
trying to think they're gonna go off
like six seasons because they're
starting because they developed the
whole serial killer kind of branch and
FBI
yeah that Johnny Douglas who's
phenomenal great books so he started it
and right now they're just that they're
just getting to the BTK killer they just
got done with the Atlantic killing so
they do the real the real doubts that
Oates who all yet based off true story
Johnny Douglas though actual guy who
created the division yeah is like in the
he helps with the show you know because
he there's a guy who places so you're
actually seeing the race is oh yeah oh
but it's just drama time yeah
it's rustic but they're gonna have like
and you get a sense of their minds and
it's amazing yeah it's amazing and how
and but also they're hunting them down
and they're and they're interviewing
previous serial killers to try and
figure out how they're gonna catch this
one like what were your motives which go
back to the murder site why these
victims and they put together profile so
they can catch the other this BTK guys
such a piece of [ __ ] is that what people
in my business you know we call that a
mark and he's acting like he's he's he's
just acting like he's got some kind of a
career at it what are you talking about
the BTK bind torture kill this guy
Dennis Rader
yeah the serie killer that guy yeah when
they interviewed him you ever see the
interview he's crazy man yeah with our
interviewing I mean he's the head of his
true I drove by and I said that would be
that probably be a good mark right there
and
in my business we call that out you know
whatever [ __ ] yeah nobody people but
they interview I mean he's very
matter-of-fact the kemper the if typing
temper and minehunters the the way they
I'm telling me they get it down to a tee
the the the actors and the real serial
killers it's yeah look at rideable look
at this this was the closest I'd look at
this yeah for sure
it's insane really good cuz Kemper was
uh eight the horrible circular really
horrible which strangled girls and boys
and horrible killed his mom ripped her
throat out letter and severed her head
oh so he had it the only reason he got
cottagey turned himself in oh he was a
really smart guy highest IQ they've ever
had of yes that's right in fact yet so
that there's a story did they have this
in the thing where the that's the FBI
profiler is sitting there interview him
and he goes you know I can kill you
right now rightness because you know the
card shift right now and this is their
shift and there's just no they said that
Johnny Douglas who's you know the guy
who came up with all this the profiles
for serial killers said he's what the
smartest person he's ever said brother
sat down was like Jesus Christ he would
have been caught if he didn't want to
get caught that's what's scary Wow
what's crazy is the Atlantic the Atlanta
murders of all black children there's
twenty nine of them yeah they still
haven't thought they haven't solved in
heaven they solved two then they got one
of the killers there is that was a guy
has a Nick day at two but they convict
him with the two adult murders thinking
they're still not they still don't link
him to the child murders but because
they they were like nope he did it in
the murder stop horrible but in but I
was watching this documentary on it you
want you any the parents from all the
murdered children like this guy didn't
[ __ ] take the guys out there like and
they think it was multiple people they
don't think it was just this guy crazy
[ __ ] done man yeah what love Wayne
Williams you get these monsters oh my
god while I was telling my girl because
in Atlantic Atlantis Atlanta keeps in
Atlanta City but in Atlanta
kids were just going missing their kids
I like playing outside and doing stuff
and he would get them supposedly by
saying oh I have a talent contest and
I'm a manager and you get him studio and
then whatever you know murder him but
you know 29 kids go missing in a summer
Tigers not good he's not going out to
school and you're back bad and we're
gonna shut it down I remember that was
in the eighties early 80-77 yes in the
example I remember it pretty well that
was a kid but I remember it crazy right
just yeah and ammonium well I remember I
remember my aunt not Beatty should
always pick us up from school and
sometimes she couldn't she's a you know
the big thing was kids get abducted in
vans that was the big thing yeah not
anymore though
you're not getting no [ __ ] kidnap van
well strange to put on your Instagram
they have their these guys come up with
ways to do things let's the remember
when Mitch I was telling us that that
kid went missing in a Walmart or
something and they shut everything down
but then they found the kid in the
bathroom he'd been he'd been dressed up
he had his head shaved Earl she had her
head shaved that's right and put in boys
clothing yep these people prepare this
stuff oh yeah they try to think of all
angles a lot of law it's not on impulse
all these premeditated well even that
that Kemper
he was so cerebral about it yeah then
his IQ so high he would stop they call
him the co-ed killer dude stop and see
young girls hitchhiking and he'd come up
and go where he was all he's all
preconceived to make him feel safe here
where you going like you know they're a
laugh yeah he said he would always like
look at his watch like this got just a
little too far yeah I'm sorry
should I go it's all right and they keep
talking like you know what all right and
the door would always be locked because
like so he said it would trigger them
like a safety thing like oh this guy
didn't want anyone in the car he didn't
have time to drop me off like all right
and hewed unlock the door for and then
they'd oh he goes every time they'd get
in they felt safe they would kill him or
or want one person killed we'll move on
from killings after this one person was
his neighbor and him his neighborhood
drinking buddies
and he killed his neighbor's kid if they
were drinking buddies and the neighbor
goes yeah you know then they're talking
about kids getting abducted and he goes
our passwords unicorn oh mention it
while they're drunk right so he's like
and he said I seen as he told me that I
knew I was gonna murder
what is this the guy who lifts up the
car yeah he goes I knew I was gonna
murder his kid as soon as he gave me
that password so that you know the kids
go so it was murder he was like 14 so in
the kid was walking with a friend and he
knew that then he pulled up and he did a
trial run and went hey I'll give you a
ride to school or how about you ditch
school today and I'll take you to go see
the pig farm because there's a pig farm
and the kid was like alright cool so he
say they did that just to see if she was
comfortable with it took the pig farm
mutts go by he didn't realize they were
walking he goes hey you want to ditch
school go the pig farm too I'll take
both use plan to kill both hit her and
her friend and the friends like mom good
something you know it had a weird
feeling and then sure enough she gets in
the car but this area got caught cuz she
was a witness nope the only reason yet
nope not at all he joined the the the
that Pasadena hunt it was like y'all
let's go over here and then he they even
found the body he's a classic terrible
man nice guy crazy right yeah that's
what they do camp I'm an art narcissist
yeah and they want to be famous of
course I don't really think you can like
they caught the BTK killer by basically
dissing him and one where they're like
you know he's not around anymore no he
got caught no he I got ya your time here
countin like [ __ ] you talk about
almost 20 years later yeah that's right
no he got from DNA evidence oh he wrote
I thought he wrote like they wrote
somebody wrote something basically
saying he's dead he's not I've been hard
beating I'm still [ __ ] around I'm
still alive yeah he'd always send he'd
always go straight to the media cuz they
want to create this near if he even
10/10 Raider be a mess with his own name
lucky we had began series 11
communication so local media directly to
his arrest in February 2000 baby damn in
2005 yeah
how crazy is that he started killing
people in 1974 yeah
but here's that here's what I'm saying
about this today I was watching this
weird behind-the-scenes thing on mine
hunters because I finished the season or
this morning is if you're sure killer
now you're really not gonna get the same
like these guys you know whatever
legends or the [ __ ] people celebrate
them but you know like there's these
they get they turn to these monsters and
dig it books and movies written about
them this day and age it's just when it
happened no there's too much content
you'd be that you'd be the subject of
the week yeah three of mass shooters
they killed more people than these
stupid [ __ ] yep mass shooters stupid
[ __ ] the mass shooter you can you name
the kid who shot up the Walmart in Texas
no they do it on purpose now they don't
highlight these dumb runs yeah but the
thing is is you're you're the you're the
you're the flavor of the week moment I
think they only go down in history like
the solemn buying kids tell me a
different time you [ __ ] yeah
so now they do it every was like alright
well we have a problem let's figure out
now it's not about who does it obviously
it's white males most time it's not
about them it's about how are we gonna
figure out it's gonna happen it's kind
of it but we don't acknowledge that
dummy anymore right so they're not
gained fame for they might get Fame from
their dorky friends out in the forums
that thing home they were gonna do it
and so it's still just that dorky form
frame but as far as I getting national
exposure
the media has figured that out they
don't even show their face yeah they
talked about the victims and even the
victim you're the flake but again the
sad thing is you're the flavor of the
week yeah yeah yeah you're not gonna be
cemented in history you dummies
there's too many and there's too much
content out there next yeah I heard that
on Rogen who is that the congressman
with the eyepatch Crenshaw yeah I like I
like him I like his eyepatch yeah he
said he said that only a 2.86 percent of
all murders are caused by assault
weapons oh he said he said did he say
hammers or Harris kill more people yeah
how is that I mean his eyepatch is
distracting it it looks like smart hair
looks cool but when it doesn't have the
strap on it it looks like it's Photoshop
huh very like new a yeah that is weird
doesn't that look Photoshop
who's it I guess he closed it to his uh
stud though man yeah he's a stud we
talked about him a while back did he
David all with PKM Sonya I immersed some
youtuber came after me he was like bro
just chill out you know Pete Davidson
nothing looks as Bluetooth leaves dots
the three lights handsome guy stud smart
- he's very slick but is it true can you
look that up is it true more people die
by hammer think guns find that very hard
to believe I believe that he knows he's
I do that if he says it he's a
fact-checker that guy's thorough more
people were killed by him there goes fu
no no no click on the second one done
there you go
don't click on his quote more people
killed by hammers clubs than right that
makes sense because hammers and clubs
are more those more access - yeah so
should we ban hammers right I told her
mm of hammers and clubs that would kill
with the rifles of any kind yeah hold on
hold on figures for our six seven people
were killed in blood with blunt object
while four and three were killed by
rifles mmm but hunting rifles that also
counts for hunt I guarantee that's
hunting accidents that's also hunting
accident you say killed by rifles you're
talking about mostly you got it would
see just suicide and accidents are huge
so you gotta bring that in too it is it
is an intern when Hillary Clinton talks
about gun violence and she cites these
things she's she's conflating suicides
and accents and she said that's a [ __ ]
lie and she's and then she knows better
and the left does that a lot
and it's just not they're not being
honest they're you're not being [ __ ]
honest you got to be honest you got to
be honest with intentional homicides
also a lot of its criminal on criminal
stuff so you know and that's crazy
though more people yeah a hammer club
blunt object linked guns that makes
sense though because it impulsive if
you're gonna kill someone
so in rifles include bolt-action
pump-action single-shot and
semi-automatic that probably includes
shotguns as well as as well as those the
left describes as assault weapons this
means only a percentage of the 403
deaths attributed rifles with them
carried out by ass
all weapon yeah it's very interesting
yeah it is when you get into the details
you like oh [ __ ] well I don't follow it
closely enough yeah what he said that
like you I thought there's no way but he
is a palo 2500 people were killed with
knives or cutting instruments that's a
lot 1,500 1,500
I would assume cuz those are this means
nearly four times the many people were
stabbed to death and killed with any
kind of rifle I would assume because
those those passions of crime yeah those
aren't done with guns usually those are
done with knives and hammers yeah you
know so if you were to ban assault
weapons you're still not gonna really
put in them you bit some I think I think
it's such sensational crimes though it's
so [ __ ] unforgiving when somebody
comes into a club and blasts everybody
so that's it's understandable that
everybody's like you know that we all go
we got to do something we all want to do
something you do something whatever
we're doing is not working yeah yeah
some nuts ain't paying guns yeah but
just maybe a gun and let me train I
think the people if you own a gun I
think you should train it you should
learn how to use it you should [ __ ]
be trained I don't know how to do that I
don't think that's gonna stop what's
going on yeah but education and training
really important if you owned guns in my
opinion let's go to curtain events sure
so an australian vegan woman is suing
her neighbors for barbecuing in their
backyard
amongst other disturbances she's saying
that her neighbors are doing this
because they are trying to make her life
basically a living hell she thinks that
them using their backyard to barbecue is
impeding on her ability to use her
backyard and she's also citing that
they're kids playing basketball in the
backyard is also impeding on her ability
to live right next door sounds like kind
of a mess sounds like a [ __ ] is there
anything worse than a bad neighbor she
says I think so the kids can't play
basketball and they here's the other
thing they're grilling fish fish really
doesn't smoke or stink now if they he
was doing like a full rack of beef ribs
and it's on the grill for the the smoker
for 20 hours alright even then shut your
[ __ ] trap so you know yeah shut up
also shut up and
she took it all the way to try to get it
heard by the Supreme Court each and
every Court has denied her yeah no
that's time for this I don't have time
hey well move yeah you're cooking also
your chances are anybody you move next
who's gonna eat me you're cooking
outside too so I you know I did hear
those those those vegan burgers out the
what the whopper beyond the beyond is
impossible or beyond impossible is like
one version of the beyond me but all all
Burger Kings have those impossible
burgers now the beyond meat burgers yeah
I guess they're phenomenal I'm sure they
just like it here's the thing are you
sure if you're vegan it's cool but it's
still not healthy for you we all realize
that you realize that right here
you know you probably more healthy just
eat the beach so I made in a lab we
never go in health today also you should
be in birding for hell my mouth's
waterin some aquatic bird
dude my favorite burger on this planet
and the rest we can suck my fat Elon now
you take is a whopper on that C bunt a
soft seedy bun yeah
whopper with cheese ketchup only God
really maybe cuz you like to feel like
breaking my plan while I get two of them
Diet Coke that's it [ __ ] your fries is
anything the whopper is a bit to me best
burger on as far as fast food goes best
better than in and out I think in and
out is so overrated that's not it Jen
but in and out is the [ __ ] to me what a
shitty bun what a shitty hamburger it
looks like even even the picture it's
like guys the impossible that's the
impossible burgers Wow whopper with
cheese only made god that thing is to me
she's impossible burger good for them
was that Sam you had a Big Mac um ten
years ago yeah anymore didn't feel good
after idea I feel pretty great after I
eat it somehow
my dad was starving when he got off the
plane yeah last week so I'm like what do
you want you anything you think it's
close like it's 10 o'clock I don't know
man
so we're in chick-fil-a it's easy yeah
it was driving me nuts yeah he he's he's
like y'all thanks for the food right Tim
and my stepmom and they're eating the
string says whatever listening is
on that chick flying over 40 years all
right that's cool
they've only been around for 30 let's go
I had yesterday I was shooting a scene
and Tim Meadows had Kraft singles on the
table for you know for the same token
single yeah Kraft singles you know
cheese so I'm looking at it like the the
just the square cheese Oh looking at
advanced it and I go there good I go I'm
eatin one and I ate it it was don't know
a really [ __ ] out of it it was so good I
go god that's good god damn it that's
good some American food is just
delicious oh come on and there's no
wonder it's called um that that Frank
was a member called the San Vicente
bungalows it's like this exclusive place
where when you go there they put out
sticker on your [ __ ] camera your
phone camera no cameras there like all
these stars there they hand out late
night grilled cheese Oh American grilled
cheese oh I like your life right real
cheese [ __ ] out of those a nice Keagan
Machado who's a great guide you know he
can just a great guy and we were eating
the [ __ ] out of those big toast grilled
cheese they were like that exactly like
that I'll eat that right now I'll eat it
now like a little tomato on your grilled
cheese I'll take that I'll take it no
intimate right now that's what they hand
out i man your boys you can mean grilled
cheese nice to make size and growing up
a stop that how do you how do you do it
how do you get it like that I wouldn't
even know how to do mean how do you make
it that letter and then you you you make
the sandwich right now he's like so
butter butter cheese yeah and then I put
it on the pan like grill one side to
gets a little toasty okay I flip it girl
that side that's it and the cheese melts
oh I'll do it now how do you not how to
make a grilled cheese I don't know but I
want to do it made bacon grown up well I
had a staff I I don't know I would just
just stand there and open my mouth you
know but you put in my mouth my mouth
with ham to ham that's [ __ ] good too
mmm so you know you switch it up
enjoy that this high last I want a thick
cheese I'm gonna have a grilled cheese
you know where we should go where it's a
little far I went my goal in the GTA or
juice that my mouth's waterin me neither
oh I have to be on set I'll build it
myself
this would get her an events Oh what is
next let's do it let's do some current
Oh weird so Kevin Hart is currently
facing some backlash for an interview he
did a while back that just came out it's
in regards to to him saying that lil nas
ex coming out wasn't that big of a deal
I saw and I saw what he was saying yeah
just a tiny clip of authority yeah this
is the clip that's going viral and with
all that early success you thought it
was important to make a an announcement
was that that's actually my question why
do you feel it was necessary to come on
and say that it's not there like his
like being forced it's just like knowing
like growing up like I'm wrong I'm
growing up to hate this [ __ ] I'm not
supposed to like hey hey what homo-sex
Kevin looks drunk why people come on now
why if you're really from the hood you
know you like you know like it's not
some so it's like if for me the the cool
do with the song on top of everything to
say it is any other time like I'm doing
this for attention in my eyes but if
you're doing this like while you're at
the top you know it's like for real and
it's like sewing like it doesn't really
like matter I guess there it is now I
did yes Kevin for that yeah doesn't he
buddy Keith they say he keeps interrupt
him as though I don't know what he's
trying to say Brendon was he was trying
to say cuz I read the whole thing what
he was trying to say is is he was going
he was going they shouldn't give you a
hard time it's just no big deal you're
just gay so what he was trying supporter
he was not supportive but and and what
they were saying is he was it it's all
[ __ ] this is a small group of people
being funny I've watched the clip so I
thought that's the that's the whole
Clippers I thought about watch the clip
sometime Kevin really comes off poor
he's gay so what to colonna's ex ability
to say
for himself to me derailed and downplay
the combo like we know no need to
discuss it move on it's not cool he was
gay so what Kevin knows Kevin Kevin
Kevin Kevin has apologised he's a
[ __ ] good guy he means everybody
everywhere all the best and these are
[ __ ] idiots leave him alone that he's
not the bad guy you dummies leave him
the [ __ ] alone no I think he I think
that looks a little drunk a little
buzzed but you could tell he was saying
like why don't you know that's not a big
deal that you're gay like he's trying to
say it's a good thing that you know he's
very tall people oh my god want to
borrow some eyes anybody he's a little
little knows a little mouse point he's
like but it is a big deal dude um but it
is like it's the business in the hood
I've talked of famous [ __ ] black
actors and I think if I've even heard
Kevin talk about this in the hood in the
black community if you come out as gay
or you start talking gay you will get
it's it's it can be a career killer it's
just it was it but that's what the yeah
that's that's right that's the point
yeah it's can we go now why it's not a
big deal and little I was like no
actually yes dude it's kind of a big
deal for me now I think Kevin was trying
to say it you know so what yeah exactly
you know what he was trying to do but
people and sounds like he's on fire and
kid where we just interrupt people so he
gives us like yeah that's what we do
that's what Kevin does he's the best all
right I haven't hard acting like you
don't know why the Naz would be scared
to come as like someone who stole this
the thing you lost I've got people
here's the thing is the media just wants
to jump on all everything they love
again again none of this matters
all this will be gone by Friday more and
oh my god
Oh heaven little ass little NAS ex he's
probably like yeah I don't give up and
also BuzzFeed and all these [ __ ]
wanted you you don't care you don't
matter you just you're just looking for
click how many people taught my Dave
Chappelle special now and all the uproar
but how about over how about this where
the NATO's the critics gave him 17
percent the fans gave 100 percent so
yeah so again the critics who are
activists and little [ __ ] just shut
up you know they had to pull the pullers
account though
Rotten Tomatoes in imbd cause so many
trolls went on there to give them a
negative rating yeah
alrighty next one yeah
so the Eagles offensive linemen were in
the ESPN body issue and their photos as
well as their interview is getting a lot
of traction play this clip you shown the
pictures the interview is like five
minutes lucky this oh god is it fats
healthy now again hold on hold on these
are fat dudes there's a lot of fat in
this picture there's a lot
oh no no no they are not healthy ah they
look just big yeah I guess there's
muscle too though right oh yeah a lot of
moss a lot of fat though fellas well
Samoan a lot of Samoan [ __ ] going on
that guy in the middle doesn't look fat
at all he just looks biggest my guy in
the middles Jack Jack the white guide
the lineman with the bald head there's a
fat guy that's not an epitome of health
those guys say it too they were asked a
question in the interview what would
they do after football and a lot of them
said that they're excited to get lighter
and not have to eat to gain so much
weight yeah I see them nuts look at the
size of them there their legs and [ __ ] I
mean those guys are just also huge men
so they've got some bellies again the
far right has straight up tits dude yeah
ha mwah
what are we sort celebrate this now like
uh a lot of people are celebrating it
because it's body-positive
but they don't look bad they just look
big kind of big meaty dude some look
alright some look fat bell Brian I need
help
these are is my prom I hate oh we accept
this now yeah they're mine this is and
you know why everyone accepts it because
most people look that way yeah that's
why we're all like no you can't do that
like now you're fat fat no I also like
the fact that you say it's not healthy
you're not as healthy as you could be
and stop acting like it so that's what
football requires so for their position
you have to be as big it's possible
Dostal nimble on your feet so there
those are old linemen usually I think
those of you guys are a little more a
little thinner right
no just depends yeah if they're detail
some fears if you're if you're a D
tackle you got to be faster than right I
mean you got to be you'll be pretty
explosive yeah look up uh Aaron Donald
he's the best player in the league he's
a defensive lineman think he's six -
best player in the league
go to a shirtless pic shirtless yeah
this is what this is what you want to
celebrate the body issue this what
should be Jesus click on the second one
inch in GA sees 300 pounds oh well he's
up he might be like 290 I find what it
is board my board I'm sorry were you
saying about body issue in those fat
guys wow this that this is a freak this
should be on your front of your magazine
not the fat guys yeah it's a big fella
does play in the league there you go
number one
300-pounder huh he might be 270 I forget
what he is but he's like an enormous
yeah that's plenty
yeah everyone's trying to do is wait for
me chew six one short 24 shorts dowdy
dude perfect guy pick fella and he is a
defensive tackle yeah yeah makes a lot
of money I'd imagine oh yeah yeah super
baller what else we go this is for Brian
Alex Honnold he was on the also on that
body issue yeah check out some of the
pics here yeah so um there's wonderful
he's a studdy right there ingrained them
in my brain know them live the
affiliative them I got some more pics
here God Amelie just forums veined of
that right down the top that's cool he's
a spider he's a spider he's a human
spider my favorite is when this got
posted people were talking [ __ ] to me
and Andrew Schultz like oh not an
athlete like nope never said that never
said that I don't think he's the best
athlete in the world
shred city though I guess it got deleted
it's a good picture there right this
picture got deleted and one of these
weird I think the only UFC fighter is uh
that's a good picture
good good lighting right there that
picture asked RIT we got the point
though yeah that's cool that was one of
them his forms are nuts yeah yeah okay I
saw this someone tagged us in this stuff
too and it didn't make sense to me
something called the glass helmet
project that LeBron James is doing it
seemed like it was a joke but if you
watch the whole campaign it looks like
they're serious about this oh you know
we're out board is LeBron James
this is for basketball no football
because you're their whole point is when
you're a football player your your heads
covered you guys are even talking about
this before the stand out I'm not famous
enough yeah cuz they're just this later
this terrible idea
I'll lay here LeBron real quick yo
what's up you know being a part of
uninterrupted we always want to do
things that can help empower - athlete
and I believe once again we're doing
that you know go back to my football
days there was always a stigma about you
know players being inside of helmet and
them not having no voice no one knows
because he's time and no one ever truly
knowing that there's actually a person
inside there and not taking that
seriously so you know with the great
people uninterrupted and us being able
to brainstorm and us to be able to do
some great things I want to show you all
what we're bringing to life which I
believe is very important that will get
it out man football player himself but
for everyone to let you know that you're
always more than so this is the first
never been seen and as you see right
here is said they will be seen
uninterrupted this is he's serious I
don't know it's the first glass helmet
he has to be joking behind it is all
these great athletes that play our
wonderful sport of football will be
heard and will be seen oh he's not
saying where but they are at the end of
the day they are people as well okay
he's joking take these helmets off and
there are people Nona when it's
he's making I see what you're saying
he's trying to say that it's a glass
helmet because they're more than the
helmet so it's a glass helmet so they
will be seen so maybe it's just a
campaign where they take pictures with
it ah yes the ideas with it on but Brian
I am more than this I'm more than
exciting players I am a father I'm a
leader oh I'm here to make you okay yeah
for a second I thought he was
legitimately trying to do a little
confused by a see-through helmet message
but okay because if you put padding in
it you're not gonna see them you're
missing the whole thing yeah you know I
know it's just they all it is like yeah
it was confusing campaign okay then we
gues decided play football yeah I am
more yeah paramedic I know that are
there another note sense or no there are
other causes that might well yep but the
other thing yeah you talk about you talk
about feeling sorry for the
millionaire's but the other thing is is
they're like we're more than fancy
football players like I'm more emotional
state yeah we know but I just wanted you
to have a lot of catches for my fantasy
football yeah I know your dad and [ __ ]
like that but although to his point like
when Andrew Luck was gonna retire me
what start booing them yeah they can't
yell do you know that makes them feels
like human being man there are more than
football players but this is yeah
there's definitely some other causes I
fight for Chiron jr. like Taco Tuesdays
right what else you got gin
alright the Kevin Hart crash there's a
couple updates this one I saw yesterday
apparently the 911 callers said that he
saw Kevin Hart being taken out of the
driver's side of the vehicle by his
bodyguards
and then they took him to the house to
get help but as of today I guess CHP
said it was definitely Kevin Hart that
was in the passenger seat due to
evidence okay but it but so uses the
pastor she so what's the prob well if
you I mean when you first heard about
this crash it was weird
right because you see him in a video in
the driver's seat peeling out and the
guys like chill chill out and then later
on if CHP said he was in the passenger
seat I'm gonna believe his yeah but also
you know he didn't go get an ambulance
he got his he went to his house yes I
was always kind of weird and why would
he drive up no he didn't sees that he
was
incoherent and his with his wife calls
me goes there's something pulling on his
spine
yeah his spine sticking out Oh his wife
also sounded just like shoes little buzz
you're drunk - when you hear on the
phone yeah it's very strange yeah it was
really weird
I'm sure there's a lot more to this
story I'm sure there's stuff we don't
know for a fact yeah yeah but he's in ok
surgery right now though or he got out
he's successful it was successful
surgery
he's been saying he's supposed to do
some promotional stuff for Jomon speech
they had three spinal fractures is that
what they thought huh and that's lumbar
and thoracic areas
she was perverted by [ __ ] she was the
vertebrae endure a very long rehab yeah
he's uh currently in extreme pain
heavily medicated yeah that's that's no
joke yeah now it's no joke and he was in
the car with his trainer or his his
buddies weina yes it is his friend and
his wife and she happens to be a trainer
for an eco heart yes life yeah
Jared black was supposedly the dragon
huh there we go
all right this is in Mexico a girl who
does a lot of yoga and she does it on
her back patio she fell from the her
balcony 80 feet died no no
she survived but she has really really
bad injuries it'll take her about three
years to recover 11 hours of surgery she
was considered to be in critical
condition as Monday has suffered
fractures to both legs in arms hips and
head so they had to reconstruct her legs
maybe three years before she even walks
again she's 23 yeah she's she's pretty
too she's a young girl
Cody here's the thing what the [ __ ] were
you thinking I don't know what they're
thinking stupid she wasn't what do you
think you know that's what we love yoga
80 feet off the back of your felony back
and feet yeah that's impressive
Amex one has arrived eighty feet oh she
was 80 I mean I'm sorry
she was Mexican yeah is it Mexico
Hastings are [ __ ] town
tough tough like you'd eat [ __ ] all the
time think basil strong [ __ ] like Kevin
Gosselin okay does anybody have better
chins and [ __ ] Mexican fighters
keep going this is Michael Rapaport I'm
sure you guys have seen this by now I
haven't I haven't okay this is at the
big three game and he's trying to
interview this guy Cuttino Mobley and
the guy wants to pretty much kick his
ass good access with Cuttino Mobley who
I know which is he was on the core
people here at sport yes a them I mean
my man is looking custom suit sharp
Cuttino this is a tough game killer
threes are not playing around
what do you have to say about this game
my man I feel like it's a bit of an act
I don't know could you know what we just
told me he would put hands on me on live
TV CBS sports big three playoffs if it
happens it happens let's make sure you
keep that videotape for my lawyers mom
dad it was great a great run while we
had it it's not the first time
somebody's told you I think I think it's
an ongoing bit cuz another guy did more
I think I think it's I think it's
pre-determined
it is who conceived really held up
rapport I cannot watch big three I find
it sad they have a four point for god
sakes
I love hands off I'm glad it's going
well for him all right one more sure
this was amazing
this pilot he was a trainee I guess this
is only a third lesson his instructor
passed out
from a seizure so he had to land the
plane himself yeah
well hey if you hear the audio call here
this guy is super good like super cool
[Music]
after this commercials you could hear
the nerves an Australian student pilot
Mac Sylvester's voice as far as probably
Maori roll
in fact it was Max's third lesson
through verse I'm in there when I'm
landing an aircraft ever
and inside the Cessnas cockpit max's
flight instructor had just passed out
Max's response was literally
fight-or-flight did this have to do with
situation that you've been throwing in
front of you neither reacts incredibly
with the towers guidance max brought the
plane down without a scratch you gonna
show you kids up you know having issues
like that flight instructor was rushed
straight to the hospital where he's now
in stable condition but I should be a
flying start again definitely
you look like Bradley Cooper but you
don't in you look like his brother who
didn't get the job right guys price
shouldn't be a flight instructor though
you know
viola blood pressure issue all right I
gotta go act kids all right cool go back
you know I'm saying buddy see me okay
September 27th or 28th at the improv
Tampere improv come and see me Brenda
where are you gonna be ice house next
Thursday with my crew i South Pasadena
come on by dude yeah I South Pasadena
shopping friends that thing's almost
sold out one show only that's next
Thursday and then I'm in Houston
September 20 through 21st she's been
improv Denver is almost sold out
hometown Comedy Works downtown Denver's
the 26th of 28th of September and then
just on sale Pittsburgh and Philadelphia
for October get your tickets now chief
at kake.com is that it dude that's it my
brother just a fine kid those are the
worst shots I've ever seen we're out
there given to me